and i've i've i haven't been fired a lot
but i've been fired before where
i sat there and i hung up the phone you
know the producer calls me and he was in
tears because he was like this is a
shock
i you know we already shot the thing and
i remember he says
like i just want to get to it but you
know this is the way it is
and and i said hey listen let's not make
this weird i love you i love working
with you let's just you know hey we'll
keep in touch man i appreciate the job
and i hung up and i i it was one of
those moments where i'm numb
you're numb and you look at the ceiling
and you see the one
spot of black or whatever it is on the
ceiling and you just stare at it
and then i took a deep breath and i go
my dog came up to me and i go oh but
look i have this dog
and i have a roof over my head and i'm
not dead
and i started to say these gratitudes
which kind of helped even though i half
believed them half didn't but
i've been in that position where you're
like okay
and you're almost embarrassed i think
you are i think part of it's
embarrassment like everybody's going to
know i got fired no one's going to hire
me i
i'm you know it's it's a very difficult
kind of thing you can easily spiral
downward but i didn't without a doubt
that's why it's important to i'm sure
your dog pulled you out of it you know
but
it's important to to have uh you know
you know to to have that strength of
mind i think you know i i you know
i say i did a documentary a couple years
ago on failure
in the acting industry and it's really
interesting how
at first nobody wanted to talk to me
[Laughter]
oh i i'm not touching that you know
i don't touch a face
but you know once i started kind of
opening up the subjects and
talking about difficult times they've
had in their careers or
a bad review series or bad reviews a bad
word
you know you start to understand it's
just another part of the business
that you have to navigate that you know
yeah you could be on the highs the highs
are great
eyes are great getting work
money all that's great but the lows are
loads are hard and sometimes the lows i
think
you learn more in the lows than you do
in the highs
it's in the lows when you sit there and
go let me figure out let me
think about this
think about this i mean how am i doing
today you know you really have to
work on yourself and really kind of get
in touch with with with
you know with something that i i you
know i think
will teach you resilience you'll learn
resilience you know you
you don't learn anything from success
you know you just bob along when
everything's going well yeah it's
great it's only when you hit a hard time
that you go
let me ask you you start asking yourself
questions start thinking
am i tough enough to get through this
i'm like am i resilient enough to get
through this
can i you know can i push through this
difficult time and
i've had difficult times you know right
now things are
great but um if i hadn't had those tough
times i don't think i'd appreciate
the times i where where i am now
so i you know i i see i see i see those
dark days as
as a part of the business and um
to be to be embraced just as much as
the uh yeah